[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com so after multiple denials the
New York Times and CNN are both
reporting now that Saudi Arabia is going
to admit that yes journalist for The
Washington Post
American resident Jamal shogi did die at
their Embassy in Istanbul Turkey and the
implications are very far-reaching to
say the least we talked yesterday about
the story and we talked yesterday only
about what we knew at that time which
was that although everything pointed to
Saudi Arabia having a hand in and likely
being responsible for the death of the
journalists they had vehemently denied
it multiple times including reportedly
to Donald Trump and we spoke about the
geopolitical implications we talked
about the economic implications and a
lot more and at this point on the facts
nobody should be surprised that
Khashoggi died in Saudi custody or at
the hands of the Saudis that's been
pretty obvious for days and the way
specifically that Saudi Arabia according
to the reporting we have right now from
the New York Times and CNN and this may
change by the time you listen to this or
you watch this
Saudi Arabia is going to frame this as
it was an accidental death due to a
botched interrogation at the Embassy in
Istanbul now there is also visual
evidence of him entering that embassy in
Istanbul which we are we have on the
screen behind me for our television and
video audience and as a reminder before
we get to sort of the full explanation
that we're anticipating from the Saudis
yesterday I played video for you of
Donald Trump proposing really in a way
that provided cover for the Saudis that
it could have been random rogue killers
amorphous nameless unknown rogue killers
who took the journalists out here
just a reminder of what Trump said
yesterday with that being said the King
firmly denied any knowledge of it he
didn't really know maybe
I don't want to get into his mind but it
sounded to me like maybe these could
have been Rogen killers who knows we're
gonna try getting to the bottom of it
very soon but his was a flat denial
yeah so did Donald Trump say this
sincerely when he said it yesterday if
so it would suggest that Saudi Arabia
was directly lying to Trump personally
and we would hope that that would have
repercussions but we'll get to that
Saudi Arabia initially again saying they
know nothing about it
had nothing to do with it despite
information from very early on that one
of the few places that khashoggi went
when he was in Istanbul was to the Saudi
embassy there and specific information
suggesting he was not only murdered but
also dismembered there new explanation
is reportedly again as I mentioned and
alluded to this was an interrogation
that they were doing of Jamal shogi but
the interrogation went wrong and he
ended up dead and as the details come
out the story gets even more bizarre
Turkish officials are claiming and
believe me I know that when the Turkish
officials claim something we have to be
cautious and skeptical Turkish officials
say that a Saudi autopsy specialist
entered the country carrying a bone saw
in a group of 15 Saudis who came into
Turkey the day that Khashoggi
disappeared this has all the markings of
and appears to be yet another
disgustingly brutal and atrocious act by
the Saudis and what is you know we often
say 50 people shot in Chicago over the
weekend but it's this one person that
got shot in South Carolina that makes
the news or 10,000 kids died of hunger
in Africa yesterday but the two that
died on the London subway make the news
consider how many people in Yemen have
died at the hands of Saudi Arabia over
the last year that doesn't mean that the
khashoggi story is an on story but it is
part it's always a media story as well
what makes the news the interrogation
gone wrong explanation that could be
right it could be it's very interesting
though like was he threatened with a
bone saw and wouldn't cooperate that
with them so he ended up getting
dismembered we have to know the details
about this was the bone saw brought in
after he had already died in order to
you literally take him apart I mean it's
[ __ ] it's gruesome what we're talking
about here and it's also important to
understand that if Trump didn't come up
with the rogue killers theory himself
and he was really told that by the Saudi
royal family this means they're straight
up lying to the president which would
hopefully carry some diplomatic
repercussions but in the era of trumpet
it's not it's not clear that it will
rogue killers is sort of accurate in
that it's this the Saudis behave like
rogue killers right and in that sense it
is sort of accurate but beyond that I
think we know that it that that was not
an accurate assessment and the real
problem is that we seem to have this
dictator believing dictator friendly
White House right now and it is a story
about Saudi Arabia but as an American
show this is also a story about our
relationship with this brutal regime the
story from Saudi Arabia was never
believable right embassies are very
secure there are cameras everywhere
there are visitor logs and security
checks the idea that Jamal khashoggi had
been at the Embassy and two weeks later
the Saudi royal family still just didn't
know they weren't sure or they hadn't
heard that he had been at the embassy
was laughable from the beginning the
only question is have they been straight
up lying the entire time and do we
believe that it was an interrogation
gone wrong and I think you're right Pat
that it could have been but it's also
just as likely if not more likely that
it was an interrogation followed by a
deliberate execution and they're calling
it an interrogation gone wrong because
we'll never really know and even if the
Saudis did lie to Trump it's clear that
he's not going to do anything about it
you know things said during the 60
Minutes interview that he wasn't
considering sanctions and that there are
other ways supposedly to punish Saudi
Arabia over this but he also made it
clear that he wants to keep that 110
billion dollar arms deal and for him the
life of this one journalist just isn't
worth that money well this is important
because this is it is one journalist it
is one life that appears to have been
brutally ended early it's an American
resident it's a journalist working for
The Washington Post the idea that we
would accept as a reasonable explanation
that you know it was an interrogation
and the Saudis miscalculated and he
ended up dead whether it's true or not
is irrelevant because it's not an actual
explanation that would say to us
oh well no repercussions are warranted
the repercussions here are ones that
we've been calling for for a very long
time if it's this that causes that to
happen great it may just expose the
degree to which Trump is just enamored
and complicit with brutal authoritarians
all over the world I genuinely don't
know what the follow-up will be but you
can be sure that we are going to be
covering covering it
it appears that Robert Muller is at
least initially going to question Donald
Trump in the Russia investigation in
writing
meaning that trumps lawyers will be
allowed to write totally innocuous
probably non perjury answers to
questions from Robert Muller if this is
all that is going to take place as far
as the questioning of Trump it's a total
disaster so this is according to sources
that are directly involved with the
process they told CBS News that this is
going on importantly we don't know
whether this is it for Trump's
involvement or if this is just step one
when CNN first reported it one of trumps
lawyers Jay Sekulow said no comment and
CNN said we don't know whether this is
the first of multiple rounds of
questions or if there's the possibility
of asking follow-up questions or if it
will culminate in an in-person interview
we just didn't know and it's been a huge
topic of contention for months now we
know that this rotating cast of lawyers
that Donald Trump has has been trying to
avoid Trump sitting down in person with
Robert Muller period and we knew that
they wanted written questions and
answers and at least based on the
current reporting there will be a round
of questions and answers in writing but
we don't know if this is a precursor to
the real interview or not Rudy Giuliani
says we are not prepared to agree to
more questions until this first group of
questions is asked answered and someone
can explain why that isn't enough
reasons why only written questions are
not sufficient includes that sort of
like what the FBI investigation of Brett
Kavanaugh was not sufficient because it
didn't even
include questions to Cavanaugh there is
no opportunity to explore whether Trump
is telling the whole truth if you just
do written questions write that phrase
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth it's easier to enforce
that when you can follow up with the
person and they're sitting right in
front of you because Trump's lawyers
will likely stick to the truth in their
answers but they're not gonna volunteer
the whole truth and this is one of those
cases where the whole truth is really
where Trump could get messed up and end
up exposing the obstruction the lies the
possible criminality and the most
pressing question is why would Muller
allow this and there's a few
possibilities
number one if Robert Muller starts to
think he's not going to be able to get
an in-person interview that if he has to
subpoena Trump that the subpoena would
be ignored or challenged then maybe you
say is Robert Muller if this is all I
can get I will do some written questions
that's one possibility the more sort of
clever or devious explanation would be
maybe Muller is so well prepared that
he's hoping to get some lives or
contradictions in writing from Trump's
lawyers because they may not know what
Muller already has and getting lies in
writing would be much more powerful if
they are Trump's sworn statements then
the sort of subjective offhanded
comments that you might get during an
in-person interview but I'm thinking
like super optimistically here yeah I'm
leaning towards that second second
explanation because the Moller
investigation has been going on for well
over a year at this point so you have to
imagine they have quite a bit of
evidence and they know what went down
and you know maybe this is the best they
can get out of Trump because he is a
sitting president and he is so busy yes
of course but tweeting about horse-faced
or me they could definitely catch him in
a lie or a few lies here the truth is
that if Trump did collude with the
Russians or obstruct justice or whatever
else he's probably lying to his lawyers
anyway so you may end up in a situation
where what Trump's lawyers present to
Muller are lies but they are Trump's
lies in other words his own lawyers may
not even
that those are lies and Bob Woodward
actually describes a conversation
between trumps lawyer Jay Sekulow and
the Muller team where Jay Sekulow and
maybe even John Dowd also say we can't
let Trump look like an idiot because the
transcripts will be released other
countries will realize that Trump is a
quote goddamn dumbbell that's a quote
and that type of thing but I actually
don't know that that's really a concern
in the sense that it's a concern that
other the other leaders think Trump is a
dumbbell but they probably already know
that if they've dealt with him I don't
know that transcripts of an interview
with Muller would really it would really
expose that but to go back to Muller for
a second the most interesting theory
I've seen about why Muller would agree
to written answers for now is that he
may not think that he can legally
subpoena Trump successfully now and get
him in the room but if he gets written
answers that directly contradict what
other witnesses have said maybe that
would give him stronger legal
justification for pushing for the
enforcement of a subpoena it's a
hypothesis I would just hope that these
questions are falsifiable right I hope
he's asking did you know about the Trump
Tower meeting ahead of time did you know
that Russia was trying to help and
influence your campaign because yeah
sure lawyers can kind of work their way
around that but in the end those are yes
or no questions and Mulder may already
have an evidence to confirm that those
are things Trump knew or talked about or
met with Dettol at the time what I think
is most likely to happen here is what
happened with Cavanaugh I hate to be
pessimistic but it will be listen he
answered the questions there was nothing
obvious in the questions that justified
mandating or forcing an in-person
meeting and we're gonna have to continue
the investigation just on the basis of
these written answers that's what I
believe is the most likely outcome here
but I do want to hear from you about it
I'm on twitter at des Pakman the show is
on twitter at david pakman show the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new member of the day
is Kenneth Johnson Kenneth thank you we
do depend on the support of viewers
listeners who sign up for membership or
pledge on patreon
today's sustaining longtime member of
the dais Lynn Fletcher dating all the
way back to August of 2013 lensman with
us more than five years
Kenneth Lynn thank you join them at
wwe.com pennies a day pennies a day to
support independent media or at
patreon.com slash David Pakman show
this next story would be sort of dumb
sidebar were it not for the fact that it
goes to the total debasement of American
politics and basic honesty in our
country and it's the story of
Massachusetts senator Elizabeth Warren
who's been attacked for a long time for
claiming Native American heritage in her
family she's been ridiculed for this
Donald Trump has made it a habit of
making fun of her by calling her
Pocahontas many times I could play 15
minutes of examples for you here's just
one right just to give you a sense of
how he does it you'll have plenty of
those Democrats coming over and you're
gonna say no sir no thank you no ma'am
perhaps ma'am it may be Pocahontas
remember that
Donald Trump also previously said that
if Elizabeth Warren took a DNA test and
released it and it showed that she had
Native American ancestry or as Trump
likes to call it that she was an Indian
that he would donate a million dollars
to the charity of her choice and
Elizabeth Warren has done that she's
published her DNA results it seems to be
more about 2022 try to be able to say
listen I've dealt with that issue if she
does indeed want to run for president in
2020 then her about then about her
campaign right now here in Massachusetts
which she's going to handily win and a
Stanford professor Carlos Bustamante
who's an expert in data science and
genomics said that as in genomics our
genomics its genomic think it's genomics
I say genomics said that the vast
majority of Elizabeth Warren's ancestry
is European but that quote the results
strongly support the existence of an
unexpected
somewhere between six and ten
generations ago which critics will point
out ten generations would mean that she
is 1/1000 24th Native American so the
immediate questions were number one why
is Warren doing this now answer again I
think it's about getting it out of the
way if she wants to advance a
presidential run in 2020 interestingly
Donald Trump is not ready to donate the
million Trump was asked about this
yesterday morning and he straight-up
denied ever having made the promise to
donate a million dollars check this out
[Music]
you better read it again now here is
Donald Trump himself making the promise
and tell me Pat if my ears are deceiving
me this is from July 5th where Donald
Trump said exactly what he denied saying
there and we will say I will give you a
million dollars to your favorite charity
paid for by Trump if you take the test
and it shows you're an idiot
yeah shows you're an Indian I like how
the crowd cheers that like what are you
what are you cheering there right well
maybe that's providing him covered right
because turns out she was Native
American partially yes not Indian she's
she is no she's not claiming any Indian
ancestry dating back to the Indian
subcontinent he can argue he was kidding
he can argue it doesn't really show that
she is Native American if she's only one
one thousand twenty-fourth Native
American but how can they argue that he
never said it and while we're at it
didn't Sean Hannity say he'd get
waterboarded if something or other
happened and he didn't do it I think
that that's also a promise that Oliver
just remembered I would like to see that
maybe he could make it longer than
Mancow muller did what was that like
four seconds or seconds waterboarding
torture so the latest is Trump says he
will only donate the million if he can
test Elizabeth Warren himself I don't
even know what that means like he's not
he's not a DNA I don't want to know what
that I don't I don't want to know what
Trump imagines it would mean for him to
personally test Elizabeth Warren's DNA
in any case does anybody find it odd
that if you have a drop of African blood
according to some of these rightists
you're black but if you have a Native
American great-great-great-grandmother
you're not Native American and it's okay
to mock you as Pocahontas and I want to
be like crystal clear here okay if you
are arguing that Elizabeth Warren has
not experienced setbacks in her life on
the basis of being Native American I'm
with you okay I have seen no evidence
whatsoever that whether or not Elizabeth
Warren is 1024 Thor won five hundred and
twelfth or whatever it is Native
American I have seen no evidence
whatsoever that she has suffered
setbacks in her experience in life as a
wealthy sixty something year
woman if I'm wrong show me the evidence
there is no question whatsoever here
that her Native American heritage is
minor it's more than mine I mean I have
none like I have no Native American
Heritage period in my background so she
is more than me but does it relate to
her experience as a person in the United
States of America no I don't think so
but if I had an Italian great-great
great-grandmother would it be okay to
start calling me
Guido sarcastically or whatever right
like if I had an Irish ancestor is it
acceptable for the president to jokingly
mock me as Mick or something that's the
point here which is again the debasement
of the politics and if you want to come
to me and say no David the real problem
here is that Elizabeth Warren actually
received an advantage on the basis of
claiming this Native American heritage
come to me and prove that because I've
not seen that people who say well she
was classified at Harvard as Native
American that's different than being an
affirmative action admission on that
basis and I've not seen evidence of that
to the contrary there was a
comprehensive Boston Globe study that
looked into this yeah and it proves just
that that she wasn't admitted on the
basis of her being Native American and
that wasn't even considered it was more
just about how she was listed in the
faculty directory yes she wasn't doing
this to get ahead or anything like that
and again I don't believe that there
would be any reason to afford her that
getting ahead because I don't believe
that she was hindered in any way by this
supposed Native American heritage which
we now were told by a genomics that
award that that it is a likely part of
her of her ancestry send me your
thoughts about where you are on this now
here's where I really want to get into
that this is the main story for me from
the Elizabeth Warren DNA situation the
question for me is not what is her exact
Native American ancestry it's partially
about Trump lying claiming initially
that he would donate a million bucks if
she has a DNA test that shows she's
Native American then he said he never
said it now he says he wants to test her
DNA himself for me the most interesting
sort of
after effect of the DNA story is that
the Russian troll BOTS have been
activated hugely there is a really well
put together reddit post that points out
that the hashtag Pocahontas Trump's
nickname for Elizabeth Warren as well as
a whole bunch of other terms as you can
see on screen like Native American DNA
and other terms were trending on
Hamilton 68 which is a website that
tracks Kremlin propaganda as well as on
a website called the bot Sentinel which
also tracks troll BOTS and fake news
accounts Russian trolls are specifically
posting and reposting and linking to a
fake news article from true pundit which
straight-up claims that Elizabeth Warren
faked her native-american ancestry if
you look at the top posts on a
notoriously Russian troll riddled
subreddit called the underscore Donald
as of this morning eight of the eleven
top posts from the prior 24 hours were
related to Elizabeth Warren and if you
classify or sort of categorize the
comments and the positions that are
being espoused the ones that are getting
the most play on the Internet are number
one the average American has more Native
American DNA than Elizabeth Warren
number two Harvard had her listed as a
person of color and number three
anything less than 1% doesn't mean
anything so the question is why why
would Russian trolls and bots focus on
the Elizabeth Warren DNA story which is
a seemingly sort of transient and niche
story that's not gonna have any major
coverage even a week from now or a few
days from now and the answer appears to
be that the answer appears to you I
would say when you ask yourself what is
the objective of the Kremlin in all of
this right why is the Kremlin meddling
in our election using Trump to their
advantage the whole point is to
destabilize the u.s. and to create or
grow cracks in the social fabric to
distract to keep create strife
particularly among racial lines the
Elizabeth Warren DNA test results
themselves aren't the important thing
for the Kremlin air
but filling the internet with posts and
fake news articles about apparent
obsession with the story distracts from
stories like Russian collusion Trump's
taxes Trump blowing up the trade deficit
despite claiming as terrorists would fix
it and the really important part is that
it draws out the racists remember that
two stories that activated the Russian
troll BOTS were the baltimore police
unrest and the Ferguson Missouri
protests both were highly racialized
stories and this is straight out of the
Russian geopolitical playbook the book
foundations of geopolitics by Alexander
Dugan specifically advises that in the
United States what Russia should do is
use its special services to fuel
instability and separatism and
specifically to promote quote
afro-american racists Russia should
according to the playbook from 1997
introduce geopolitical disorder into
internal American activity encourage
ethnic separatism and racial conflict
that's why the Russians love the DNA
story mentioning DNA at all brings out
the racists it's got an overlap as well
with the race and IQ crowd and in
general any story that helps split
people among racial or ethnic lines or
gets people thinking that way is good
for Russia and it fuels the exact kind
of instability that Russia wants and
additionally the Russians may already be
anticipating that Warren could be a
strong presidential candidate in 2020 so
why not have the double benefit of
starting to litter the internet with
this type of stuff about her that is the
most interesting element for me about
the Elizabeth Warren DNA story which is
that it has become a favorite story
instantly of the Russian trolls and the
Russian BOTS send me your thoughts make
sure that you are following the show on
instagram at david pakman show follow me
on instagram at david patten quick break
back out
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome back to the david
pakman show
the documentary filmed the devil we know
is out on iTunes joining me to talk
about it is America's lawyer Mike
Papantonio who's featured in the film
for his work on the case against DuPont
and a toxic chemical called c8 which was
dumped into the Ohio River Valley you
can also find out more about the film at
the devil we know calm so perhaps since
we last spoke about this case a lot has
happened here and at this point there is
absolutely no doubt about what DuPont
knew and when they knew it I guess maybe
to start for people who don't know when
they hear Teflon they think we're
talking about the end product itself
those non-stick pans but we're actually
talking about a chemical that's used in
the production of Teflon so maybe we
start there and sort of how you became
aware of this and got involved well I
was hired by an attorney that had worked
on this case he was actually a corporate
defense attorney some pretty interesting
kind of combination but he was brought
in he had a family member that was
having serious serious physical problems
and he was actually and this was this
was 15 years ago he was brought in to
take a look at it as he started looking
at it he found that people who are
raising cattle along the Ohio River or
the tributaries are along the Ohio River
that the cattle were dying of very
specific kinds of illnesses birth
defects all started looking exactly
alike the way that they would manifest
themselves the cancers that started
showing up in people all along the river
and so what he did is he asked me if I
would if I would try the case and so we
had we we had a couple of test cases
that we tried that we started off with
in Ohio in Columbus Ohio which is
typically how this is Han
you'll have in this case you had 3000
people that were affected you actually
had 70,000 people that their water was
contaminated but 3,000 people actually
signed up and showed that they had very
specific kind of medical issues ranging
from gastro-intestinal to to cancer to
testicular cancer and liver cancer
kidney cancer which were all consistent
with the c8 exposure the their own
documents dupont's own documents showed
that they knew as early as the 19th
1970s that this this product had the
ability cause cancer and they dumped it
in people's drinking water all along the
Ohio River why do you think that this
story which when you consider the amount
of people that are in population areas
that are touched by the Ohio River I
mean the number of people affected by
this is staggering if you include all of
the ways people are affected by this why
don't you think the story got the
attention that for example the Flint
water crisis did when we compared you
know strictly speaking a lot of people
were affected by this runoff well the
media didn't have they didn't have to
worry about advertisers with the Flint
story there were no there were no
corporations that you could point your
finger to they're our only politicians
that the media could go after here the
story was in front of the media the
national media for about 30 years and
they chose to do nothing because DuPont
was such a huge advertiser for them I
mean they were massive advertiser for
the media so the trade-off was we won't
talk about this you keep spending 2
million dollars a year with us on this
ad campaign and we'll let things go
that's exactly what the media did the
meet the media was owned and operated by
DuPont for three decades and so that's
why this story did not really surface
until actually we went to trial and the
jury came back four times and hammered
DuPont four times and not only not only
said that you did wrong but they
punished them for the conduct was so
callous it was such ugly conduct and so
then all of a sudden the media had to
actually be Joe
analyst rather than advertising agents
for DuPont
and so that that's when the story
actually started surfacing story's been
out there a long time people were
drinking this water people in most
cities around the country have it in
their drinking water it's so you know
there's this is this film shows the film
I got to tell you I've been involved in
several documentaries David the
filmmakers in this first of all are huge
award-winning filmmakers but they did so
well at the Sundance Film Festival that
the folks at Sundance determined that
there were three films that they needed
to that they needed to help get the word
out on those three films this was one of
them because of the social and cultural
ramifications the health ramifications
of this of this catastrophe that was
caused by 3m and DuPont primarily yeah I
mean the film is great not only in terms
of how its produced and it shows both
the kind of personal impact on the
victims it shows the legal process that
was going on and and and and shows how
those two things relate but it's also so
important in my mind because what you
just described about corporate media's
reluctance to cover the story we have a
justice system that as you know because
of the space you work in it
overwhelmingly focuses on street crime
and not nearly enough on corporate crime
and also white-collar crime corporate
media mirrors that corporate media also
focusing on the salacious and sort of
neat and compact street crime stories
versus these corporate malfeasance
stories so you it's not from the
documentaries and independent media I
don't know how we would even learn about
these things you wouldn't no no you
would not have that's the interesting
thing about it here's something that is
so ubiquitous it's it's just out there
and so such a broad expanses this film
talks about they're even finding it in
polar bears in the Arctic so that shows
you that it's virtually in everybody's
blood at this point God didn't put it
there
DuPont or 3m put it there and now so
what what the industry did and the film
is very good on showing how the industry
captured the EPA and they not only
captured media they captured the EPA and
they they actually were hiring people
out of the EPA they would go to them and
say Joe we know you're doing this study
but by the way how would you like to
come to work for us for three hundred
thousand dollars a year you know you're
making a hundred now what do you think
and so all of a sudden this revolving
door started with the EPA with the DEP
the Department of Environmental
Protection all up and down the Ohio
River Valley but you mentioned the DOJ
this is a really ugly part of it the
both the Eric Holder administration had
all of this information every bit of it
they had possession of it they had
reviewed it they chose not to prosecute
even though any I you know I've been a
prosecutor and I can tell you they had
so much material that it was virtually
impossible for them not to get a
conviction of several of the people that
were involved in this but they chose not
to because as you point out these people
they look different they're dressed up
in suits you know they have MBAs they're
not they don't look like the kid on the
street corner in the hoodie that goes to
prison for life if he's caught three
times selling drugs these people were
not even investigated by Eric Holder or
by a scruff I could go right down the
you know right down the path well I want
to talk about immigrants it made no
there was no difference between the way
the Democrats handled it in the way the
Republicans handled it it was all about
DuPont handing out big amounts of money
to all of these politicians yeah when we
would talk to you including about this
case and others you during the Obama era
you were very hard on the Obama EPA and
on the Obama Justice Department and and
correctly so what's going on with the
current EPA in the Justice Department oh
it's worse I mean you know we well I say
it's worse I don't know that she could
have gotten that the last EPA was
basically dysfunctional you know granted
the people that they had appointed
didn't look as bad but they were they
were corporatist now we now we have for
example the the head of the
chief litigator for BP with this new EPA
chief litigator for pp is in charge of
the Department of Justice the
environmental prosecution for
environmental cases in the country he's
the guy in charge of that he was just
appointed by Trump approved by both
Democrats and Republicans the guy's a
thug I mean I as you know we handled the
BP case we handle them all along the
coast here he's an absolute thug and so
but now he's in charge of the EPA so so
yeah the he made the news we heard about
him but to tell to tell you there was
any real big difference in the
appointments of Obama it would be very
it's a tough stretch really to say yeah
they sounded better on paper but when it
came to really enforcement they were
really nothing but Wall Street
corporatists they were Democrats yeah
this guy's Republican yeah but he's a
corporatist he's a corporatist
environmental agency leader right so
there's no difference we want to thank
god this is this is different this film
is really good at talking about these
issues we're talking about right now I
mean these people did a wonderful job on
this film yet there's a scene in the
film actually and this is what I wanted
to talk to you about next which which
sort of puts out there the idea that if
an individual were to show up at a river
or you know at a downtown somewhere
where people are hanging out and starts
sprinkling arsenic around that would be
a crowd like they were get arrested for
that that would be a very specific crime
but that better go to positively what
corporations and in this case what was
happening with c8 is this bigger than a
Justice Department like is this more
about the protection that corporate
entities provide that lead to basically
fines being paid and no real people
going to prison
well there's a you know there is within
the area of the law there's this really
he's kind of a nut I mean he really is a
nut his name is Posner he's a federal
judge up in the Chicago area and he he
is he is engineered and pioneered the
way that we ought to review cases and
he came up with the economics of law
yeah a corporation may do something
completely deplorable they might kill
people they might poison people and give
him cancer but this idiot
I've very easily call him an idiot he is
he's an egg headed idiot named Posner
he's a federal appellate court up around
Chicago he he said well yeah we're gonna
kill people but we have to look at the
economics of killing those people do
people are people employed at that
corporation so it may be it's okay to
kill people it may be that there's the
economy projected because of that
conduct well maybe it's okay to kill
people that's the new norm within the
federal judiciary and certainly is the
new norm within the Department of
Justice I just can't tell you how bad I
I just almost can't put words to how bad
Eric Holder was and we thought he was a
hero didn't we
oh he's he's he's appointed by Obama he
must certainly got to look out for
consumers where he didn't he did not he
is we see the same thing with opioids
I'm seeing exactly the same Eric Holder
footprints on the opioid litigation as I
saw in this litigation with DuPont so go
figure you know that's just the reality
you know they're it's tribal politics is
the only reason we say that we're going
to preserve him as a hero he's not a
hero last thing I want to talk about
when we last spoke about this there were
sort of two I believe major plaintiffs
at the time and there have since been
some verdicts what's the sort of
totality of the cases and verdict so far
on c8 well I mean the verdicts have
range anywhere from two million to eight
million dollars I mean if they had had
DuPont not come out with a first phase
of settlement we would have continued
being in trial now the way the
settlement is built there for next five
years people come forward coming forward
with these injuries have the right to to
either try them or settle their cases so
it was built with that in mind because
there's some latency to this you know
you don't you're not exposed to see day
one and have cancer day two
so there's some latency involved and and
that's that's why these people still
have the right to come forward you can
find out more about the film the devil
we know at the devil we know calm it's
also available on iTunes and it features
attorney Mike Papantonio who's been
talking to us about the case
ah thanks as always for talking to us
thank you David
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
anytime we talk about the deficit and
the national debt at this point I find
it irresponsible not to remind you that
this is a political football that and
deficit aren't something that
Republicans actually care about they
care about it when it's a Democrat in
the White House Democrats also play the
game although more in a sort of reactive
way when the truth is that debt and
deficit matter depending on why we're
going into debt and growing the deficit
and I've talked about that before and
we're gonna get into that again that
being said we were told that Donald
Trump was going to cut the deficit he
was going to get us out of this deficit
problem he and his ilk have identified
that this is a major problem and they
were gonna fix it but we now have new
data and the United States budget
deficit has grown to its largest in six
years dating all the way back to the
Obama presidency the US budget deficit
is now larger than it was at any point
during President Obama's second term the
government is actually spending more in
2018 and the deficit is increased by 17%
to 779 billion in the current fiscal
year and according to current estimates
the budget deficit will surpassed a
trillion will surpass a trillion by 2020
and this is there's sort of two sides to
this right there's revenue and
expenditures Trump's tax cuts revenue to
the government have caused a decrease in
the growth of government revenues from
zero point from 1.5 percent last year
two point zero four percent this year
Trump's also spending more on the
military not exactly where we need to be
spending more at this point so the
important story here for me and I've
been making this effort whenever we talk
about debt and deficit probably for the
last what would you say year to year and
a half that we've been taking this sort
of approach the important story is not
the deficit itself it's why we have a
growing deficit and it's Republican and
Trump hypocrisy on the issue the latter
the hypocrisy you know about by now they
define social responsibility as
balancing the budget and then they come
in and they unbalance the budget more
than anyone
George W Bush did it Donald Trump is
doing it now the hypocrisy you're
familiar with once we realize that the
deficit in and of itself isn't the
problem that in a growing economy you
can have a deficit that grows in terms
of raw dollars but that doesn't
necessarily mean that it's growing in
terms of relative size compared to the
economy what really ultimately matters
is why the deficit grows in our case
right now the deficit is climbing
because business has got a tax cut and
Trump is spending more on the military
to really simplify it right and the
tariffs aren't going to help since
they're going to affect tax revenue as
well in general when business income
goes down tax revenue to the government
from that income also goes down just
perfectly logical if the deficit had
climbed because imagine that we gave a
tax credit to the poor and we combine
that with spending more on education
that would be a much better deficit for
the economy and it would be a different
story altogether if the deficit had gone
up because we decided we're gonna
subsidize alternative energy and we are
going to make cuts to the number of
bases that we have around the world that
would be a really good way for the
deficit to expand we need to take that
view on debt and deficit it's not this
Republican Democrat thing of deficit
good deficit bad balanced checkbook good
unbalanced bad as long as it's the other
parties guy or gal maybe at some point
what we have to understand is that not
every deficit dollar is created equal
and this is one of those things where
neither party benefits from pointing
this out they it's sort of like a race
to the bottom because the other party
will play the deficit bad surplus good
game everybody has to play it and you
never really end up getting honest
discussion about it from our elected
officials
yeah it's typically the Republicans who
went out on this issue even though you
know Bush raised the deficit Clinton
lower the deficit Obama lowered the
deficit Trump raised the deficit yeah
and remember Trump promised that even
though these numbers didn't seem to add
up he said that there would be so much
economic growth under his president it
would make up for all of it it would
make up for all of it and actually we
could cut we could pay down the national
debt by the end
his second term yeah so far we're
growing it we're continuing to grow it
and more importantly at an even faster
rate but again the we we've got to talk
about that but we also have to talk
about the fact that this is a losing
issue in general because it's being
discussed in terms it's a losing issue
for the left because it's discussed in
terms that the right has established and
that is really important to understand
here I think some people are going to
like this one to Republican operatives
from Arizona pretended to be communists
and donated to a Democratic congressman
to try and make him look bad and they
got caught and they look really really
stupid these two guys used fake names
they used the name's Jose Rosales and
Ahmad Cydia they walked into the office
of Democratic Congressman Tom o'halleran
they said hey we're here to make a
donation to the congressman in cash they
had $39 and 68 cents in cash and they
wanted a receipt for the donation
written out to the northern Arizona
Communist Party so they go in with this
money the finance staffer for
congressman O'Halloran tells them all
right fill out paperwork and you're
gonna get a receipt by email and when
they were told that the receipt would
come by email and not in in person on
paper they crossed out the email that
they had originally written down on the
form and they put in a different email
address and that rightly made
O'Halloran's finance person wonder why
are they doing that that's sort of a
weird thing to do they did a little
research they figured out that these
were actually Republicans donating to
o'halleran under fake names and this is
the best part Lindsay Coleman who's the
finance director she drove with the $39
and 68 cents in cash over to the local
Republican field office to return the
money
imagine this she walks in and she sees
the guy who claimed to be Jose Rosales
in the office except everyone in theirs
calling him Oscar he used the fake name
to make the donation would it be
surprised if you had a name tag on its
death awesome something else yeah he
accepted the cash back from O'Halloran's
finance director the other guy was also
using a fake name you might be shocked
to hear he wasn't really a mod cedilla
the northern arizona communist party
member spokeswoman for the republican
running against O'Halloran said this is
news to us no one from our campaign was
involved in this juvenile stunt so first
and foremost this is a crime it's
against the law to donate to a campaign
under a false name this should be taken
seriously you know we we hear all the
time about people are voting without IDs
and duplicate voting and whatever barely
happens when it does it's usually a
right-winger trying to prove a point and
when they get caught which is usually
they need to be prosecuted because it
needs to be shown that it is really
serious to do this stuff and along those
same lines this should be prosecuted as
fully as possible but if you haven't
heard about this tactic before this is a
really old trick
Trump's buddy his henchmen I guess we
would call him who I've interviewed
Roger stone he used to work for the
re-election of Richard Nixon he was
supporting Nixon's re-election in the
early 70s and he started sending
donations to Nixon had a primary
opponent who was very anti-war and Roger
stone started sending donations to
Nixon's primary opponent from the young
socialist Alliance the idea being that
you can later say this is outrageous
Nixon's opponent was taking money from
the young socialist alliance so this is
a very very old trick and maybe the even
dumber part of this is that wouldn't a
true communist there are already very
few actual out-and-out communists in the
US like there's a bunch of Social
Democrats there are some socialists
there aren't really that many communists
would communists really be supporting
centrists in the Democratic Party
especially ones like Tom o'halleran who
used to be Republicans like is that yeah
the Communist Party in the u.s. is going
to support that should be the first red
flag the other red flag would be that it
came from the northern Arizona Communist
Party like how many communist parties do
you think there are in here as oh no yes
there are northern a southern and
eastern and western you don't need all
those if communists are actually out
there donating money in this way I
imagine that they would pick like the
furthest left Democrats that they could
find right you're not going to say you
know who the Communist Party really
needs to support former Republican
centrist
Tom o'halleran right like it it's stupid
to the core and of course we know that
the right needs to do this stuff to win
they need consider all of the tactics of
the right gerrymandering of course voter
suppression whenever and wherever it's
possible that includes purging people
from voter rolls restricting early
voting whatever they can do smear
campaigns and then in this case you can
add falsifying campaign donations to the
list they need to cheat to win that is
the path forward for them all you need
to do is vote that's it if all
progressives got out and voted
particularly in midterms where the voter
turnout is pathetically low uh the
people who are trying to influence
elections with fake donations from
supposed communists I hope that they
won't have an impact anyway they
definitely have no chance at making an
impact if every progressive just got out
and voted yes Democrats certainly have
the hearts and minds of the American
people it's just unfortunate that that
hasn't been enough during the past few
elections light on the issues they still
have Republicans in control of all three
branches of government now even though
the left does represent the views on the
issues of a plurality of this country
the propaganda war has been won
significantly by the right and that's
why you still have people who on paper
should probably be voting for Elizabeth
Warren if they were able to if they
lived in Massachusetts thinking that
they are moderate Republicans and voting
for people like who's a moderate
Republican I don't know a bit Romney
Mitt Romney for example yeah I guess so
is he moderate I hope I don't get a
backlash for that I guess listen
compared to like Ted Cruz yeah I guess
we could say Mitt Romney as sort of a
moderate yeah just get out there and
vote please vote that's my message to
you we have a voicemail number that
number is two one nine two david p
here's an interesting question from a
caller take a listen to this david yes
David from Windsor Ontario
thank you what will it take you ask
Canada and the United States should
become one country if Canada's provinces
could be US states then the more you
know we have conservatives here too but
their reason
conservatives relatively speaking and
everything you do in Washington affects
us directly so it's in Canadians best
interest that they be able to send
elected representatives to Washington
CDC 20 Canadian senators even 10
Canadian senators would change
everything
yes they would you very much not gonna
happen so this is one of those ideas
that it's interesting to think about
sort of and I think that they're very
interesting sort of like under
foundational questions that are raised
but first and foremost I don't know
outside of Quebec whether Canadians have
any interest in being part of the US as
US states I don't think so
I can assure you that that in Quebec
there is no interest whatsoever in
becoming part of the United States
that's to begin with there is no way in
hell that the American right would have
any interest in any kind of merger
project with Canada like it's one of
those things where none of the parties
involved are going to be interested in
something like this well hey I mean we
have Alaska up north and of course we
have the contiguous United States so we
just be completing that stretch of land
I think we have to make that case you
can make the case and you will be
laughed at particularly by listen I know
a lot of people in Montreal and in
Quebec City and the idea of becoming
they don't even want to be part of
Canada lots of them right and the idea
of saying we will become a state of the
United States of it's just a nonce note
about if the u.s. gives up its
sovereignty and becomes part of Canada
so instead of Canada becoming part of
the United States yeah you have the u.s.
becoming part of Canada maybe that would
play well Joran served of mine I suggest
talking to the tea party caucus about
that and seeing what it is or what are
they called they've merged into
something else now like the freedom
caucus or oh I love that I don't even
remember what they're called now the
extremists in Congress caucus I'm sure
they'll be all over joining Canada we've
got a great bonus show for you today
Donald Trump now referring to stormy
Daniels as horseface on Twitter is this
the new normal in terms of how
presidents talk about things it sort of
seems to be we will talk about yet
another vile and disgusting act by our
fellow New England sports fans they
really are horrible I mean it is an
embarrassment I'm as big a fan of
New England sports as anybody Pat but
the fans revile every every week we have
a new story every month maybe we'll also
talk about the political leanings of
defense secretary Jim mattis Mad Dog as
Donald Trump likes to refer to him on
the bonus show WWE at medCom to get
instant access also become a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman and watch
the bonus show the bonus shows great
speak to you then
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
you